人という字は
2人の人が支え合っている姿を示しているというふうによく言われます
私たちが何か辛いことがあったときに誰か支えてくれる人がいるというのは本当に幸せ
なことです
そういった人間パン系がなくては私たちが辛くて生きていくことができません
だけど
こういった支え合う人間関係をずっと続けていくわけにはいきません
だってもし支えてくれる方が力尽きてしまったら二人ともが共倒れになってしまうから
です
もともと人という字は
倒れた人が自分の力で起き上がろうとしている姿を現した
象形文字です
1人本来自分の力で立つ力があります
だけど今私たちが直面している社会の問題というのは非常に複雑で難しいことが多くて
自分一人で解決することはなかなか困難です
だから私たちは
自分と同じ理想を持った誰かと一緒に手を繋いで生きていこうとしています
それが
それぞれが自分の力で立ってた乙ダム
エッジの関係だと私は思います
h は
ヒューマンの h です
私がこういった考え方をするようになったのは去年
ストップ地缶バッチプロジェクト始めたのがきっかけでした
期間バッチプロジェクトを始めてから松永さんがやろうとしているのは社会起業家です
ねと言われました
私はこの言葉を耳にしたことはあったけれども深く考えたことはこれまでありません
でした
社会起業
ソーシャルビジネスとも呼ばれます
私はこのソーシャルビジネスの関係は先ほど言った人のように支え合う関係ではなくて
h のように誰かと一緒に力を合わせて前に進もうとしていく
働き方だと思っています
これまで社会の課題というのは行政組織だったりボランティアの方々の力によって解決
しようとされてきましたけれどもなかなかそういった
誰かの前いいだけで
解決をまでに時間をかけていくのが難しいんですよね
ですからビジネスの手法を取り入れて課題解決をしようとするソーシャルビジネスの
動きが出てきています
まぶしなこれを始めたのは去年の8月1日に友人が sns に写真とエピソードを
投稿したのがきっかけです
まず始めて1年も経っていないので私は今日皆さんに社会起業家としてどうやったら
成功するかといったお話はできません
私自身がまだ全然成功したりとか
とば口に立ったばかりだからです
そのカーで今日私はここで皆さんに自分がどうやって課題を見つけてその課題を世の中
に広げようとしているのかというお話をシェアしたいと思います
今私がやっているのは
あのこれ痴漢は犯罪です
私たちは泣き寝入りしませんと書いた
カードここから発足した痴漢抑止バッチプロジェクトというものです
この半年間で何度もメディアに取り上げられたのでもしかしたらここにいる方々を見て
くださった方がいるかもしれません
これは私の友人の娘さんがお母さんと一緒に考案したものです
彼女は都内に住んでいて a
去年ません14年の春ですね高校に入学しました
それからね時間に遭ってしまってたんですよ第じゃないで
関西と違って関東の電車は安里
深夜帯しか女性専用車両がないんです
なのでどうしても逆を時間のタイミングに女性生業車両に乗ることができずに痴漢に
遭ってしまったそうです
最終後彼女は怖くて何も言えずにいたんですけれども
だんだん勇気を出して痴漢をする人にやめてくださいとか
宮見つけたりとかできるようになったんですがなかなかそれでも痴漢にあうことをやめ
られない
ここにいる方々も私ももちろんですし皆さんも同じだと思うんですけれども何か犯罪に
巻き込まれてその加害者を捕まえたいって思う人はいないと思うんですよ
痴漢問題に関しては
地下にあったら勇気を出して声を出してという標語がありますけれども会いたいわけ
じゃないんですよね
合わずに済ませたいんですだから彼女が痴漢が犯人を1人捕まえて警察にあの
ちゃんと届けを出て犯人の方も認めたあとにもう二度と会いたくないからといってこの
カードを考え始めました
でこれをつけてたった一人ででリアの通学を電車通学を始めたんです
ai 彼女は痴漢にあっていないと言うエピソード
彼女の母親が sns に投稿しました
私はねこれを見た時にすごいなと思ったんですよ
これを一人でつけて乗る勇気がすごい
だけど16歳の女の子がこのカードを一人でつけて電車に乗るのはちょっと痛々しい
からもっとつけやすい
がんばっ家にしたら他の女の子も困っている子が付タイプになるんじゃないかなって
いうふうに提案しました
生じたら彼女のお母さんが
いや本当は鉄道会社や検察が
作って無料で配布してくれたらいいのに行って言ったんです
だけど
性を持ってなっていても絶対100年待っててもそうはならないでしょう
だったら今自分たちでできることを始めてみようかそれが私と彼女が見つけた課題です
ただ私も彼女もなのを作った経験がありません
私はただのフリーライターです4位彼女は専業主婦です
何から始めていいかわからないし資金もないそこで一番精神に寄ったのはクラウド
ファンディングでした
クラウドファンディング0
プロジェクトを立ち上げたところ
予想以上に沢山の共感の声が集まりました
目標金額の50万円はたった6日で達成して結局3カ月の間に3304名の方から
20012万3000円の資金をいただきました
そして同時にクラウドソーシングでデザインも募集しています
女子高校生たちがこれならつけたいなって思うようなデザインで痴漢しようかなと思っ
て近づいた人は辞めたって一歩引くようなデザイン
そういった相反する難しいデザインを募集したんですけれどもこれも100
78名の方から441点のデザインが集まりました
私たちはこのようにして自分たちが見つけた課題を社会に向けて発信することで
クラウドという形を使って共感する人を集めることに成功しました
これがたくさんの共感を集めた理由は被害者が痴漢に遭わないだけではなくて被害が
起きないということは加害者も生まれない
そして加害者に間違えられるという冤罪被害も起きないというところにポイントがあっ
たからだと思いますつまりこれは誰にとっても安心安全な連射区
感も作りましょうという呼びかけを社会に対して
したわけです迫に共感が集まったので多くの方からご支援をいただけました
そして
ビジネスの手法を取り入れると言いましたようにこれをきちんと製品として世の中に
出していくのを目標としています
なぜなら所会社を製品として出すことで被害者を孤立させないことができるからです
あなたたちのことを気にかけている大人がいるよ
周囲の大人があなたたちが被害にあって困っているのを知っているんだよというのを
伝えるツールです
そして鉄道警察や
鉄道会社企業や大人社会みんなが子どもたちを守ろうと今活動を始めているよそれを
伝えるためにも
駅の売店だったりお店の中にこのバッジがあることが大事だというふうに私は考えてい
ます
私は今年で51歳になります私が生まれた昭和40年というのが社会というのはもう
どんどんどんどん高度成長期で
坂を上っていっている状態でした企業は自分たちが勝つんだ
winner になるというのを目指していたと思います
でも平成の時代になってからそんな風に1人勝ちを狙っていてはいけないよねという
ことで
ウィンウィンの関係をつくるのがいいよねという風に変わっています
また
ever こういった社会活動というのが注目を浴びるようになって世の中はもう一歩
変わってきたなというのを私は感じています
がどういう関係かといえばやはりみんなが手をつないで h の関係を作る
これはウィンの関係ではなく
入っちゃっハッピーの関係ハッピーとハッピーが生まれる関係だというふうに私は考え
ています
社会が持っている課題というのはもちろん置換問題ばかりではありません
学生の方々でしたら就活の問題ですとか
学生ローンの問題奨学金の問題
それから昨日もニュースになって出てきてましたけれどもブラックバイトの問題だとか
これから世の中に出て行った時に色々な問題はあなたたちは抱えていくと思います
そうした中で
こんなの嫌だと思うことはいっぱいあるでしょうけれどもそれを
何が悪い国が悪い社会が悪いと言っていてもたぶん自分にとって
ウェイシー世の中に代わってくれるということはなかなかないと思います
だけど彼女のようにまず最初に小さなアクションも起こすことで誰かがあなたと同じ
ようにそれはおかしいと自分も思っていた一緒に変えようって考えてくれる人が現れる
かもしれません
そんな風に課題を見つけて自分で動き出すことが昔に比べて非常に容易になっています
私たちはクラウドワークスクラウドソーシングやクラウドファンディング
クラウドの力を使って
間近なところには同じ共感を持っている人はいなかったけれども日本のどこかに同じも
思いを持っている人がいるというところにアクセスすることができました
その人たちと一緒に力を合わせることでいろいろな行政とか検察とかに声を届けること
ができるようになっています
ん
私たちは本当に小さな小さな事しか出来ないかもしれませんけれども
一つの小さなアクションがたった半年でこんなに大きな力を持つことができたその事例
の一つにこれからなっていきたいと思っています
今日ここに来てくださっている皆さんや動画を見てくださってる方に私から伝えたいと
したらやはり自分が何か課題を見つけた時にはまず
勇気を持って自分の力で立ち上がってください
そうしたらあなたの前にいる誰か
私たち大人も皆さんと一緒に戦っていきたいとおもいます
ありがとうございました